aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en mayo del 2011 uno de los volcanes más
activos de islandia entraba en erupción
temblor cenizas humo para los
intendentes es éste era un patrón
fácilmente reconocible pero para mí yo
que era una turista en la isla por
primera vez yo no podía crear sentía
terror y mi primer instinto era echarme
a correr en dirección opuesta a este
volcán de escaparme
en contraste y para mi sorpresa
mis amigos islandeses estaban subiendo a
sus motos de nieve a helicópteros pero
se dirigían hacia el volcán
hoy se repite esta historia estamos
todos presenciando un volcán figurativo
que está mostrando señales de actividad
con avances tecnológicos arrasadores con
reajustes macroeconómicos repentinos y
con cambios que nos están cambiando las
reglas de juego así como hizo el bien vi
con los hoteles o uber con los taxis o
el caso del látex con la televisión para
algunos estos avances tecnológicos van a
significar que vamos a poder prolongar
la vida o curar enfermedades como el
cáncer la ceguera o incluso hacernos
inmortales con hologramas que nos van a
capturar la esencia de nuestras personas
pero para otros las consecuencias van a
ser catastróficas sabemos que para el
2030 unos 800 millones de puestos de
trabajo van a ser reemplazados por lo
que es la automatización o el uso de
inteligencia artificial robots
maquinaria
y los efectos no son solamente para los
individuos hay muchas organizaciones y
compañías que ya están sintiendo las
consecuencias de este cambio
por ejemplo la antigüedad promedio de
las compañías en la lista de fortune
five hundred solía hacer 60 años hace
unos 50 60 años los años 50 hoy ese
número se redujo ya 20 años
el cambio es inevitable
y está sucediendo alrededor nuestro con
una velocidad acelerada
yo quiero contar porque me parece buena
idea hacer lo que hicieron los
irlandeses mis amigos y correr hacia
este volcán metafórico y ser
protagonistas
ahora hablando de cambios el cambio más
rotundo que he experimentado en mi vida
es la llegada de mis hijos axel y lucas
que tienen cuatro años y un año hoy en
día yo lo llamo los agentes de la
disrupción porque entraron en nuestras
vidas con este evento que tuvo al
principio efectos sigilosos como fue el
disfraz del caballo de troya entraron
con su disfraz de la sorpresa que
derrite la poca amenaza que representa
el gurú gaga
pero la usurpación de poder fue gradual
primero empezaron con la tortura doc
turn a no dejarnos pegar un ojo
dejándonos un estado semiconsciente
completamente vulnerables al ataque
luego claro llegaron las prácticas
psicológicas de separar al enemigo como
hacen las leonas cuando cazan con ellos
se posicionaban entre mis voces yo
creando una barrera física literal y
cada vez que tratamos comunicarnos nos
interrumpía
cuando queríamos salir al exterior bueno
había que estar encerrados en la casa y
no había forma de establecer conexión
con el mundo fuera nosotros la verdad no
me extrañaría si mi expectativa de vida
también se redujo 240 años gracias a
estos eventos el cambio fue realmente
radical fulminante como a causa de un
volcán enojado y sin mes y licor ya y
pensar que nosotros como padres
voluntariamente
hicimos estos bebés en q vamos a los
bebés sin sospechar que iban a
canibalizar nuestras vidas
ahora así son netflix netflix que aníbal
hizo el negocio de dvds que tenían con
la incubación de un bebé que era
streaming la tecnología de streaming
cuando llego netflix al mundo el mundo
estaba dominado por blockbuster algunos
de ustedes se acordarán ya estaba
saturado saturando alrededor de 6 mil
millones de dólares anuales y aunque
netflix ya veía señales de que estaban
por ganar esta batalla contra el goliat
del rubro ellos sabían que la amenaza
real no era blockbuster era el futuro
era la innovación tecnológica entonces
por eso a pesar de que ellos sabían que
el crear este bebé
la de streaming iba a matar a su negocio
de dvd es muy exitoso lo hicieron de
todas formas no incubaron dentro de sus
propias compañías y por eso hoy en día
podemos decir que el 15 por ciento del
uso de banda de internet mundial lo
ocupa del flex y porque ellos corrieron
hacia el volcán en vez de ignorar estas
señales y tomaron control de estos
cambios pudieron tener un desenlace muy
diferente a la de nokia o la de polo
gravitó
las organizaciones que ignoran estos
cambios hoy en día
especialmente las empresas pymes o
familiares muchas de las cuales las
tenemos en toda américa latina y en
argentina las consecuencias e ignorar
estas señales pueden ser fatales los
agentes de disrupción en estos casos
quienes son los emprendedores los
innovadores que vienen con sus cursos y
con sus pantalones llenos de agujeros y
pasan completamente desapercibidos como
cuando llegan estos bebés a nuestras
familias hasta que es demasiado tarde
les cuento 'la el ejemplo de whatsapp
whatsapp tenía un equipo de solamente 30
personas más o menos y con ese equipo
pudieron crear un valor de adquisición
de más de 10 mil millones de dólares y
hasta crearon una capacidad móvil
superior a la de facebook
ahora qué podemos hacer nosotros para
poder enfrentar estos cambios sobrevivir
estas crisis y ser protagonistas y no
tener el riesgo de ser pacífica 2 por
esta lava metafórica de la que estamos
hablando bueno les quiero proponer a lo
mejor tres estrategias una sería la de
la inspiración la el contagio y la
adopción de nuevas ideas para inspirarse
ya no es suficiente leer revistas o
escucharlos en la radio porque cuando
para cuando nosotros nos enteramos de
estas innovaciones por los medios ya la
innovación se ha difundido masivamente
ya es demasiado tarde por eso si hay
eventos como éste
en sus ecosistemas para emprendedores
innovadores inventores hay que unirse
por ejemplo en stamford donde yo fui
alumna y soy profesora hoy los
estudiantes empezaron a juntar un
viernes a la tarde con pizza cerveza a
discutir ideas sobre innovaciones y el
futuro dos de los participantes que
solían y regularmente eran estudiantes
de doctorado que terminaron por fundar
una pequeña compañía llamada google
también creo que es muy importante
activar la imaginación yo trato de
pensar en escenarios futurísticos
combinar tendencias que yo observo al
azar y trato de imaginarme que pueden
necesitar un mundo con estas
innovaciones tecnológicas por ejemplo
qué tipo de productos o servicios pueden
necesitar un mundo en el que los autos
se manejen solos y las haciendas me la
cocina una impresora 3d
yo creo que en mi caso por lo menos voy
a tener menos razones para pelear con mi
marido así que vamos a necesitar menos
servicios de terapeutas ahora para
contagiarse de este espíritu innovador
nosotros necesitamos entender y asimilar
cómo piensan los emprendedores yo creo
que los chicos nacen emprendedores y los
encasillamos más tarde en la educación
por ejemplo mi hijo axel desde que tiene
uso del lenguaje cuando nos pide algo
nunca le decimos que no le damos
opciones un día viene a la noche y nos
dice papá mamá quiero un chupetín y
bueno era muy cerca de la hora de dormir
así que le dijimos te damos dos opciones
opción una te vamos a dar el chupetín
pero entonces no te leemos las historias
que tenemos todas las noches opción 2
no te damos el chupetín pero mira
tenemos el doble de las historias que
elegís y axel sin parpadear miró y nos
dijo yo quiero opción 3
yo quiero repetir pero saber más voy a
tardar unos minutos para terminar me da
de comer así que porque en el ínterin no
me lees más historias
bueno si piensan los emprendedores
siempre buscan atajos toman riesgos
medidos y calculados fracasan pequeños y
seguido y siempre están observando y
buscando oportunidades que vienen en la
periferia de su visión como los
comediantes que van a cualquier
situación y ellos tienen observaciones
inusuales de la realidad y no sólo eso
sino que saben cómo narrar esa historia
de manera atractiva para el resto de
nosotros
para la mente emprendedora el cambio
tiene una connotación positiva porque
con los cambios surgen oportunidades de
mejorar paradigmas tanto sociales como
económicos
y muchas organizaciones compañías
gobiernos ya han creado programas para
establecer este puente con los
emprendedores y los innovadores ya sea
por concursos o por jaca songs oa veces
incluso aceleradoras pero creo que es
importante crear una cultura que acepte
el fracaso que pueda promover la hiper
colaboración por ejemplo mi colega que
también es profesora de stanford propone
que tengamos un currículum que haga una
lista de todos nuestros fracasos y lo
que aprendimos de ellos en vez de una
lista de logros yo tengo de otro
ejercicio para mis estudiantes a los que
les pido que el primer día de clases
cuando entran y anoten sus deseos más
fervientes en un papelito y los ponemos
todos en una gorrita y todas las semanas
elegimos un papelito de la gorra y bueno
el trabajo es que todos en la clase los
instructores la profesora los
estudiantes ahora nos abocamos a
darle ese problema a el compañero que
salió elegido silicio fue cumplido por
otro compañero entonces ahora todos nos
abocamos al deseo de ese compañero y así
se genera una cadena positiva
y también esta cultura de hiper
colaboración
ahora para la última etapa que es la
adopción yo creo que lo que hacen falta
son sistemas y procesos para que no se
rechace lo que es nuevo lo que es
diferente porque todas las
organizaciones tienen estos anticuerpos
que identifican y eliminan lo que es
foráneo todas las ideas que vienen del
exterior hay que suprimir estos
anticuerpos y crear una plataforma una
cultura en la que todos los empleados y
el equipo se sientan a salvo de
contribuir con innovaciones y tomar
riesgos y se puede hacer esto a través
de la contención de los fracasos en un
departamento de innovación pero cuando
hay éxitos hay que compartirlos con el
resto de la compañía como me dice la
frase célebre él
los éxitos tienen muchos padres pero el
fracaso es huérfano
todos estos eventos de disrupción la
llegada de un bebé un volcán en erupción
una crisis o los avances tecnológicos
realmente nos cambian las reglas de
juego
pero si corremos hacia el volcán si nos
posicionamos como protagonistas podemos
asegurarnos de que estos cambios no
signifiquen el fin de todo lo que
conocemos sino que sean el comienzo de
una etapa de reinvención
y en mi caso particular les puedo
asegurar que la llegada de estos bebés
terminó enseñándonos a cómo ser más
flexibles más resistentes más ingeniosos
y adaptables pero por sobre todo nos ha
enseñado cómo recalcular la dirección de
nuestras vidas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah